Jimmy has no idea what pictures we were
talking about earlier yeah we're trying
my dick photos dick photos are you
showing each other I take photos well I
don't have the fisheye lens on the
camera so I can't help you it was quite
magical I know but that was Christian I
thought all the guys were doing it yeah
yeah because I grew up in a time where
it was okay to send your dick out it was
like a way to prove you was straight to
send your penis out to your friends but
I know you can't no wyman t-shirt you
see this guy I'm a little bit older than
you so we would just do a little a kind
of courtroom sketch artists yeah and we
would give them sort of a sense of it
[Laughter]
very difficult in the Impressionist era
[Laughter]
yeah no I'm glad we've moved on from it
though yeah comfortable glad that we've
moved past I don't think we've met
budget Art Garfunkel wonder what you
would like we're here oh there it is
or no I don't think I don't know my name
is Sam Roberts
I'm an alcoholic
you're Jimmy Carr correct yeah yes okay
this posters everywhere you know who I
[Laughter]
Kris how are you feeling your whole
especially on depression he's feeling
better yeah I mean it's day-by-day right
overall I'm doing better thanks for
throwing that at me out of hers had a
big special people talked about how you
doing yeah no yeah I'm doing all right
I would say day to day you know I would
say six days a week I'm doing great and
then the seventh day a week is a living
health scape but a better ratio that I
had a few years ago so that's good okay
after doing a special like that that you
have opened yourself up to the point
that it random moments anybody like Jim
Norton can just say yeah without we
don't you know I mean you have you have
no idea like it's not even people asking
me how I'm doing it's people will just
walk up to me on the street and tell me
how they're doing and it's it's never
the happy it's never happy stories it's
terrible right it's well it's really
flattering that they trust me and that
they got something out of my show but
it'll also be people coming up to me
going hey I watched your special man I
loved it I I spent three months last
year in a mental hospital because I and
it's like whoa whoa so it is a little
bit of uh you know it's it's it's a
little bit of a door that I opened that
I didn't quite anticipate what would be
started telling people it was just an
act
someone comes up and just goes yes
that's that's that's a one-man show I'm
fine right crazy
I auditioned for the part and I got good
read I put myself on tape is amazing
those you're trying to like tell the
people how you're trying to get through
it you're trying to get through their
responses I'm gonna put my [ __ ] on him
too
yeah well you know I would most of the
time it's people who are like that
thanks for doing that it spoke to it
honestly it was nice to have someone say
something that you know people also
people come out to me like oh I made my
dad watch it he gets me more now I like
that it's just every once in a while
someone ago here's the here's the time I
tried to do X Y & Z and they get very
very specific and I'm just like wow
that's not something I ever needed to
know yeah how much how bad do you feel
for that dad though his dumb son has to
come in and go watch this guy then
you'll understand that started with you
being so nice and concerned nobody than
you being like watch this idiot no not
that I feel that's worth of his Netflix
queue that's more like it was HBO
it was HBO no but it's more it's not
about it's about that even more
depressing
yeah yeah what would be the best movie
to show your dad to make him understand
like Philadelphia have you thought about
that Chris I mean I know your dad's a
pretty sensitive guy have you thought
about showing Chris Gethard
special to your dad so he kind of my
face came and watched it live and it was
it was uh it was it was so revealing
about my parents
it was so revealing about my mom came up
to me after my show they saw it live I
did it in New York my mom came up to me
she was crying she was like I can't tell
you how happy I am that you finally told
me I can't tell you how happy I am
you're still alive we got through it
thank you
like I'm so glad we got through it
together the only words my dad said
after seeing my 90 minute show about my
suicidal issues good show bud not even
great show but good show but how he
normally talks to you yeah we're not the
most emotional relationship we need to
know there you know I love the North
Jersey dad right they're not looking to
show any emotion at anytime that's where
we're at bud we're buds I have a new
book coming out in October and I
dedicate it to him and I gave him a
galley copy like the early press copy
and the dedication says you know like
thanks him for my work ethic ever
anything I go dad I know we've never
said it out loud but I want you to know
I love you and that's true my father and
I've never changed those words and he I
gave him a copy of the book watched him
read that in front of me
and he looked up at me and went thanks
for that
[Laughter]
yeah yeah how about you you and your
parents you tell your parents you love
them or you go with that or no I I don't
my mother died many many years ago and I
haven't seen my father in not 20 years
maybe okay Debbie you know dream of good
show bud what happened with your dad I
can be haven't seen him in 20 years I do
you know it's families it's complicated
but yeah basically after my mother died
the whole thing I think that happens to
a lot of people once once the one summer
once you know one of the parents knows
you don't realize they were holding the
whole thing together right and then when
they go you go oh right the rest of us
are all terrible or not terrible you
know it's it's we don't really get along
they were the kind of the glue of the
whole thing right she wants to believe
after I'm gone everyone will be fine and
you're like no no this is over after you
know no we told that but what you want
you do this how about you Joe you go
with your parents or no this is getting
competitive now let's hear it yeah you
know talk to him no mom is great my dad
you know he same thing divorce issues
and then that's that's wouldn't stand it
was like the biggest part of my whole
life right yeah yeah that's that's what
kept you so at this moment on this panel
it's pure it has the best relationship
with his father at this moment so far
yeah yeah yeah what about you - Stefan I
know I'm I get along my dad is like a
friend but my dad when I was a kid not
but yeah my dad he was [ __ ] up cuz my
dad was in jail
when I was a kid so like for like five
six years so it's right
I think I knew that just looking at you
I think I think I could tell that like
at about a hundred yards
these dad was in prison yeah yes best
place for him it was like it was like
you know he was involved like in like
this whole like money laundering thing
he was like you mean the Mafia yeah no I
don't think he was in the Mafia but I
think you just went down with people who
were involved you know and he was like
no you know accent is so much better now
now that we know the history behind you
know I said why did not you know my dad
I never I'm not a tough guy like that
but my dad was extreme you know I used
to go to visit him in [ __ ] like jail
like the jewel of that he tells you that
like no I'm not connected with the Mafia
what but there's a bunch of guys next to
me that are and I just got wrapped up
yeah that's a poison in the car yeah you
would say we don't say Chris honestly
you'll find out about this illegal
system they got the wrong guy and I'm
just gonna do my time and my mom was
like they have five years of
surveillance footage on you Tony stop
lying you son you piece of [ __ ] like the
FBI's been watching you for years he's
like [ __ ] you I don't think it was
prison glass this conversant well no no
where was you know we could go weeks
giving yeah what's the federal federal
prison is actually not that big did your
mother ever throw like food and stuff
your father who's Janice Rossi [ __ ]
taking bread and meat out real prisons
not that bad
well compared to you know I had a cousin
who was like you know he's just like
your common [ __ ] criminal again
obviously yeah
he was just are you talking to us like
we all have people in ya Orioles in your
butt
what would you you got my cousin my
cousin it's all my father's side my
mother's side is very you know good
regular people educated and my dad's
side it's all [ __ ] people from the Bronx
New York so okay so my cousin who went
to state prison that was that was bad
you know he commented I've you know be
beaten up he'd be all [ __ ] up or my
dad just you know he there was one time
with my dad we visited my dad in jail he
wasn't even in a prison outfit he was
just in regular clothes not like that
but he was then I would know something
happen to my dad you know there are some
small shorts and a white t-shirt you
know you know regular everyday guy yeah
so it's just there's kind of like wools
when you federal prison he just make
deals with guards and everything it's
just yeah it's like not he would say it
yes isn't it
maybe now that I'm telling you maybe
he's just telling me that to like make
it sound like yes they'd be afraid yeah
yeah cuz you know what he did tell me
once that he lost God September 21st
1999 and I don't know what that means
wait when were you born 1984
[Laughter]
you never you never asked him to clarify
what do you know you say you lost god no
yeah no I never asked him why I had the
relationship with my dad I have a very
good relation with my dad it's a very
secretive like I don't tell him you know
he would if he [ __ ] walked in and I
was like I'm sending dicks and my
friends he would shoot me in the head
like he would just take out his gun so
that's why I'd have to be that's why
before I was a car I just gotta wait til
my dad dies to really explore anything
because I mean you know I just have to
[ __ ] I won't know if my dad knows I
do comedy you think he just thinks I'm
on the docks
work on the docks where's my whim sure
time for that [ __ ] where it's right next
to your bangles tea yeah so yeah my dad
I put the relation of my dad do you like
are you are you into Wham you've taken
so much [ __ ] for the shirt is it I run I
gotta be 100% honest with you I have no
idea who I am even is swear on sing-sing
prison I have no idea who this is Lost
Christmas wake me up before you go-go
that song I know for sure that shirt I
just buy t-shirts I love your dick pics
yeah I bought this shirt out of the gap
where you act like you've never done
poppers behind the shrub outside a rest
area just like this a Whitney Houston
t-shirt and I'm a big Whitney Houston
fan I love Whitney Houston coal that was
my father
huge wouldn't you say about that code
that doesn't go to your point like you
bought a Whitney here's your cutter with
dad tip and that's the opposite know
what this is I just bought this shirt of
Whitney Houston I have that shirt
that clear it up for you my dad did time
we're good friends it's the truth I I
don't know you know I just I bought the
shirt I I just I don't know it the
guards look funny to me so I bought it
not to sort of pick apart your life but
you also mentioned you were friends with
your dad you would you close to him and
then questioned you mentioned he doesn't
know you to comedy you guys just giving
each other sort of the eyebrow raise in
the house so you think well that's fair
enough yeah he knows I do comedy but I
don't think you know when he comes to my
I have to [ __ ] you know do a
different kind of show when he's around
you know because yeah he's just he gets
mad at [ __ ] you know that means it
[ __ ] convicted felon I mean this guy
he's got like he's got issues you know
he's I mean ever you know he never hit
my mom that's good he never hit my mom
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a good guy you know yeah a lot of
his friends used to [ __ ] otherwise
without my dad he was the opposite he
writes he beat her while he was in jail
yeah I mean there's ways Bobby who
wasn't my you know real uncle who you
know was Frank you know I don't know
nothing you know is it a typical story I
never told you these stories I've told
you never told you about Bobby pets now
I remember I never told you about Bobby
pets I don't regard this [ __ ] I don't I
told you that you under oath as you tell
these Bobby I can't believe you're
turning on this guy they tell us about
Bobby Bobby pets was my uncle uncle but
now my dad's brother just like of course
my your father's world you are
considered a [ __ ] snitch No
you're on the radio talking about chicks
women [ __ ] no no I'm not I'm not red
dots on your forehead I'm not he because
all these and I was able to talk about
anybody who's dead that was my dad's
woods like you want to go out there and
do your [ __ ] jokes just to make sure
everybody who you speak about is dead
and procedure that's my dad is still
with my dad so with us but yeah Bobby
pets he was a guy he was my father's
friend and you know my uncle and he when
my dad was in jail Bobby would you know
come around and like help out with like
whatever fix and [ __ ] and you know
probably listen to George Michael why
they call him Bobby pets was actually
like two animals or what he did to her
[ __ ] well no he had he was a guy like
in the neighborhood on my block he had
all different kinds of animals like you
know it started out with organic cat no
he doesn't have a canary yeah but then I
remember the sickest thing that he had
was I was like maybe 13 years old and
any call my dad wasn't in jail my dad
just wasn't around what's an uncle 13
story yeah and he cause he's like
Chrissy what's up it's pets he goes you
got to come over I just got a penguin
and I was like holy [ __ ] so me and my
boy paddy Finnegan we go down
this [ __ ] story somewhere you're
reading it I swear to God he's hot
Finnegan he's a fireman in Harlem this
is true I have four friends named Pat
Finnegan are you writing paddy flyballs
is that based on the photos that he
knows because when he gets drunk when
it's gets drunk he back pedals like he's
catching flyballs so he'll call Pat
everybody in the neighborhood that calm
paddy okay okay so so well I mean
there's no it's just he had a fuckton he
had a penguin how do I get the pink well
that's what we oh that's what we never
knew anything about Bobby pets about how
he got these animals oh I know a little
sappy quit you already know it was
[ __ ] stolen yeah well I didn't buy
that [ __ ] at Target where do you put it
in the haha that's what I'm saying that
well so we call we what we went over
there me and Pat went over there and he
had it it was a basement in Bensonhurst
Brooklyn with you know [ __ ] like a
[ __ ] Frigidaire air conditioner and
like I see a fan and he was like this is
the [ __ ] penguin he goes you know
what the best part is all I gotta do is
feed at nuts and it's good and I was
like what do you feed it knots he goes
my guy told me you just feed it nuts and
cheese and it can eat whatever and I
just got to keep the air conditioner on
I'm like it's August in New York City in
a basement if this is not Antarctic
conditions and he the penguin used to
walking around on a leash like everybody
knew Bobby's at the cops nope the police
never [ __ ] with Bobbie pets because he
was funny what do you want to have like
it he had like the Mafia
whoa yeah maybe you know and but he I
remember like but that was pre 9/11 this
that stuff yeah yes thank ya bin Laden
they're the real victims
now the penguin loving people of
Brooklyn
real victims see the best the bet you
can ask anybody who grew up in New York
City in the in the early 90s the best
summer think best summer barbecues and
hang John Gotti John Gotti used to throw
the best he was so nice to the kids I
mean I have a picture I think he like
picked me up once and he was beautiful I
mean the Mafia they do bad [ __ ] but only
if you you know no it's not my uncle my
aunt my aunt's husband got murdered by
the mob whatever happens 20 years for 20
years they never found out who did it
cuz you I couldn't find this guy for 20
years my aunt because she had you know
the kilt that killed her you know her
husband and the son to his son so they
both got whacked but not my aunt's son
and they didn't kill her even though
they knew she was there they didn't kill
her you know why cuz she was nice to us
that's what I basically so they killed
they killed the father in the Sun but
they didn't kill my aunt even though
they knew she was there right oh this is
all like a legend cuz nobody I mean we
know he's dead you know but you're his
son are dead but my aunt was there
nothing happened came for 20 years 20
years every month somebody would drop
off a bag of cash behind one of my aunt
plants in their house on Staten Island
they killed her husband they're not nice
guys yeah baby it's called hush money no
but it's the other foot but I got it
it's about respect percent on your side
on this I doubt you I think if someone
murders a family member I mean almost
thing the money makes up for a bit takes
the edge off
yeah there's always still day but that's
still $500 I'm gonna do something I was
a little kid I mean you know my dad told
me this is what happens Chris Godwin I
just want to know I just wanted to know
did Bobby pets know that you do comedy
no Bobby pets is dead Bobby pets died
Bobby pets Don I want to say 2006/2007
who killed him Pina no I think Bobby
I probably died of all you know hard
there all those guys did a heart attack
stroke it sounds like an mi ruin any
sort of childhood memories for you but
it sounds like he was definitely
definitely molesting children in a boat
well the guy with all the animals
inviting the kids to the basement yeah
have you won the most attractive of
children and maybe nothing happy
weird-looking kid I'll give you that
what happened to the penguin the penguin
he's way lives on walks around the Bronx
pets what someone brings him a little
bag of money once a month nice guy yeah
no I probably he does Bobby I moved to
all these to move around he was like
living in upstate New York than New
Jersey so you just like lose track yeah
neither lose track him but like you know
the penguin something happened to it
either died or gave it away something he
would always think we do together we
could have probably all put together
something happen I know I don't really
besides my father I don't know really
anything about the Mafia I don't even
think about your mom you're you're the
only guy I know that says something
someone got murdered and then you only
say something happen like you there's
that's it but I cuz I don't know what
happened I was five years old okay you
know I don't I don't know all right I've
never seen a dead body seen anyone get
murdered
I've seen people be beaten up but I've
never I've never seen like and all that
stuff was shielded for me besides what
my dad was in prison my uncle got killed
but everything else was she
but the rest of it was shielded I can't
believe I have my dad a little bit yeah
my dad right I appreciate my dad so much
more yeah wow it really could be worse
good yeah yeah well you you gotta get
along though saying like I can't they
don't even talk no I wouldn't my dad's
watching my three-year-old daughter
right now oh that's nice yeah it's a
[ __ ] great grandpa he's out of that
life I think I mean 72 he's 72 years old
I don't think he's [ __ ] doing mob
stuff with my three-year-old kid yeah he
column maybe it's yeah he doesn't have
God anymore no well yeah he doesn't have
God and he's got you know he's been
married to my stepmom for at least 25
years and she you know it's a whole
different and say and they bonded
because her brother was also killed so
it's all I swear to god where they meet
coffin shopping yeah so I was protected
from it all and that's why I do comedy
when [ __ ] wham shirts on now send in
my dick out I went the other way yeah
yeah you just want to be just like a fun
like I'd have no care in the world
like oh you know anything about this guy
yeah not no no I'm not
well the funniest thing was I had a
pilot a sitcom pilot that didn't get
picked up and Chaz Parmentier he played
my dad and when Chaz palm and Terry met
my father they already knew each other
like Chaz like he didn't remember my
chest like I'm trying to place your
father at my dad's like 1968 Bronx
Tremont Avenue it goes that's it how you
doing you know I like I they started and
they sat down and talked and like I got
pushed out like I was like oh this is
great like you know I'm the actor it's
my [ __ ] show and did Chaz and my dad
were telling me what I need to do with
my show and then it didn't get picked up
so [ __ ] you dad but yeah I saw these
guys know each other Mike DeStefano the
great late Mike my father had known his
family from I don't know that they were
friends well you guys have the same
spelling to your name cuz everyone calls
you Chris DeStefano
well people call me still call me Mike
these two fine
like that my woo now then they get the
practical let down he's was des and I
was DD is so but they knew all knew each
other in the Bronx all these it's like a
community there they all know everybody
it's like a community the show it's like
a community yeah
a my actually my father told me like the
Mafia really doesn't really exist too
much in the u.s. cuz a RICO Act and
Giuliani whatever you know but bottom
right far come but Montreal the Mafia in
Montreal is still very much inside but
he just told me is like the Montreal
Mafia they still exact well I prefer not
to tackle that issue I don't I don't
even know where look for it you know I
wouldn't know where to look I mean I
guess you don't off you a fine little
for you wait Joe you didn't think that
his description of the Mafia was
accurate before that they only bother
you if you bother them yeah you do think
that was accurate no Joe I'm telling you
it here's the thing if if if you are
true mafia guy would never [ __ ] with you
unless you [ __ ] with them now you have a
lot of wannabes now the wannabes they
will do something to prove a point
they'll stab you and do something but
then they'll be taken care of you know I
just want to get into it yeah by their
people but the real mafia guy unless you
[ __ ] with them they will never [ __ ] we
got